Clease Noren how to use the results in
the new personality test for progress in
life,
trying to compensate some sites that
that received fewer points,
well at the risk of sounding self.
That's actually why we developed the
self authoring suite,
was to help people improve their website
performance and mental health.
Now,
we don't have direct evidence that will,
that will improve personality,
but I suspected that evidence would take
a very long time to accumulate.
What we do know is that the self
authoring suite,
especially the future authoring suite,
um,
helps people,
helps university students,
for example,
stay enrolled in university.
It increases the probability of that by
about 25 percent and increase his grade
point average by about the same.
Then there's good theoretical reasons
for assuming that writing is a good way
of,
um,
writing about yourself and about your
past and about your future is a good way
of catalyzing personality transformation
because it appears that personality,
the human psyche is organized at the
highest level of abstraction.
Using something like self narrative and
a well-developed narrative makes the
frame for your life and helps you
stabilize your negative emotions.
And also experience more positive
emotions because you only experienced
positive emotion in relationship to a
goal and that can make goal directed
activity lot more rewarding.
So you know,
it's a lot easier to engage in
activities that aren't intrinsically
rewarding if they're linked to something
that you really find important.
And so I would say if you want to work
on your personality,
well the first thing you have to do is
figure out who it is that you want to be
and then you have to make the plan and
maybe you have to clean up your past as
well.
And the self authoring suite was
designed no quite carefully in order to
help people do that with a relative
minimum of effort.
Not that it's easy because it's not,
but a relative minimum minimum of effort
compared to other technologies,
let's say,
and like,
like longterm psychotherapy and,
uh,
to make it cost effective as well.
So.